OR I WILL CALL.
THE COMMITTEE MEETING THE ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS TOURISM THE
END OF IT AND INTERNET MEDIA
COMING HE TO ALTER.
AND MISS CONNELLY GOOD GOLF IS
ABSENT FROM THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
A GOOD EXCUSE ABSENCE SO THE
COMEY -- BUT WE DO HAVE A CAR
RIGHT NOW ALL ASKED TO SHOW
COULD HURRY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
KANSEN CHU HERE KANSEN CHU HERE
DEEP.
DAVID CHIU DAVID CHIU HERE CHOI
YEAH CHOI HERE FRIEDMAN.
MEN HERE.
THIS AREA.
HAVE A CORNER ALRIGHT GOOD THANK
YOU I WE DON'T HAVE A PRESENTER
YEAH.
WE'LL JUST WAIT FOR THEM TO SHOW
UP
.
SORRY MORNING I SEE THIS
ASSEMBLY.
A YOU HAVE ONE BILL TH -- AB.
ONE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERS ASSUME WILL ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE X. SAFETY STANDARDS FOR
YOUTH TACKLE FOOTBALL CONSISTENT
WITH SAFETY STANDARDS.
THE HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL LEVEL.
THE BILL LIMITS GAMES BE CONTACT
DURING USED TACKLE FOOTBALL
PRACTICES.
AND IMPLEMENT SMALL STRINGENT
AND CONFERENCES SAID THE SAFETY
STANDARDS IN THE COUNTRY FOR
YOUTH FOOTBALL.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL REQUIRES
CONCUSSION EDUCATION COACH
TRAINING INJURY TRACKING.
INDEPENDENT OBSERVATION A
PRACTICE AND MEDICAL PERSONNEL A
GAMES FOR ALL YOUTH TACKLE
FOOTBALL OF WEEKS.
WOULD BE HERE TODAY IS JOE
RAFTER AND RON WHITE FOR YOUTH
FOOTBALL ALLIANCE Là WITH OTHER
SUPPORTERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
MY NAME IS JOE RAFTER AND I'M
PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FOOTBALL ALLIANCE -- AS AND IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER -- I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
SINCERE APPRECIATION FOR THE
COMMITTEE STAFFING AND
CONSULTANT FOR ALL THE WORK.
TO MAKE THIS BILL WHAT IT IS
HERE TODAY.
ON BEHALF OF THE THE ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND FOOTBALL PLAYERS IN.
YOUTH FOOTBALL PLAYERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- AB ONE
PROVIDES THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE
STANDARD.
ACROSS ALL TACKLE FOOTBALL WORK
ORGANIZATIONS AND WILL ESTABLISH
A BEST OF BREED -- STANDARD FOR
ALL OF OUR COACHES PLAYERS
PARENTS ADMINISTRATORS AND
REFEREES.
AB ONE IS ALIGNED IN INTEGRATED
WITH PREVIOUS LEGISLATIVE
DECISIONS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY SENATE AND GOVERNOR --
I TO BE SURE THAT WE ARE
CONSISTENT WITH -- A FORMER
STATE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION AND
TO ROLE MODEL THE ALLIANCE'S
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT.
AB ONE CODIFIES MANY EXISTING
BEST PRACTICES AS INTRODUCED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER.
AND ALSO OFFERS NEW LEADING
PRACTICES LIKE INJURY.
REPORTING AND TRACKING.
THAT ARE NECESSARY TO CONTINUE
TRANSFORMING SPORT OF YOU TACKLE
FOOTBALL.
WE'RE HERE TODAY IN THE I SEE
THIS AS AN HISTORIC MOMENT.
ALL OF US WANT TO SAY FOR FUTURE
FOR FOR YOUTH.
I'M THRILLED TO BE HERE IN A
CONSTRUCTIVE CONVERSATION. TWO
IT TO ADVANCE YOU TACKLE
FOOTBALL FIRST AND THEN EXPAND
THAT'D ADVANCEMENT OTHER SPORTS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH FOOTBALL
ALLIANCE IS DEEPLY COMMITTED TO
HONORING OUR PAST IMPROVING OUR
CURRENT SEASONS AND ADVANCING
THE FUTURE OF TACKLE FOOTBALL.
THE TRUTH IS WE LOVE TACKLE
FOOTBALL.
BUT THE ONLY THING THAT WE LOVE
MORE THAN TACKLE FOOTBALL OUR
OUR KIDS.
FOOTBALL PLAYS AN IMPORTANT
CHARACTER BUILDING ROLE IN OUR
SOCIETY ACROSS A LARGE
DEMOGRAPHIC.
WE OWE IT TO OUR CURRENT AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS. TO RECEIVE
THE BENEFITS FROM IT.
AND ADVANCE OTHER SPORTS BIKE
CELEBRATING THE SAFETY ASPECTS
IN A MEDICALLY INFORM WAY.
I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME OF THIS
MORNING AND I WANT TO PASS THE
MIKE OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE.
MISLI STARTS.
THANK YOU JOE.
MY NAME IS LISA -- IT'S I AM THE
MOTHER OF FOUR SONS -- ALL WHO
PLAYED YOUTH FOOTBALL AND HIGH
SCHOOL FOOTBALL.
AND ONE WHO -- HAS THE PROUDEST
ENGINE OF CATCHING THE WINNING
TOUCHDOWN FOR THE PHILADELPHIA
EAGLES TO BRING ON PARTY TROPHY
TO PHILADELPHIA FOR THE FIRST
TIME EVER.
SO I'M A CALIFORNIA FOOTBALL MOM
THROUGH AND THROUGH.
AND I'VE DECIDED TO USE MY
PLATFORM TO FOCUS ON CHANGE AND
IMPROVEMENT FOR YOUTH FOOTBALL
FOR YEARS TO COME.
I'VE HAD  FRONT ROW BLEACHER
SEATS TO SEE EVERYTHING THAT A
MOM CAN SEE ALL THE JOY ALL THE
HEARTACHE ALL THE SADNESS ALL
THE STRUGGLE.
ALL THE LAWS ALL THE WINS ALL
THE VICTORIES AND EVERYTHING
THAT COMES IN BETWEEN BUT AS A
SINGLE MOM WITH FOUR SONS.
THE ONLY THING I DO KNOW IS THAT
WITHOUT FOOTBALL WITHOUT YOUTH
AND HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL.
MY KIDS LIVES COULD HAVE GONE IN%
A VERY VERY DIFFERENT DIRECTION
TODAY. FOR BOYS ALL OF THEM ARE
OUT OF COLLEGE EXCEPT FOR ONE IS
PLAYING BASEBALL.
HE DIDN'T CONTINUE ON WITH A
BALL THAT PLAYED IN HIGH SCHOOL
AND THEY ALL REMARK THAT THE
BEST YEARS OF THEIR LIVES REALLY
WERE WHEN THEY ALL FOUGHT WITH
EACH OTHER -- WITH THEIR
TEAMMATES TO WIN GAMES AND TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THEIR LIVES --
ONE OF THEM WENT ON TO BE A
OBVIOUSLY A SCHOLAR ATHLETE AND
THAT STANFORD SO YOU KNOW WE WE
ARE VERY MUCH OF AN EMBEDDED
KICK UP.
CALIFORNIA FOOTBALL FAMILY.
SUPER HAPPY TO BE HERE
[inaudible]
CHECK.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
XENON ANY OPPOSITION PLEASE COME.
FOR ONE OUNCE.
FOLKS MY NAME IS RON WHITE ON
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOOTBALL ALLIANCE I'M
ALSO THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
OF GOLDEN EMPIRE FOOTBALL ON
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING FOUR THOUSAND YOUTH
PARTICIPANTS I STAND IN SUPPORT
TODAY OF AB.
ONE THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
WE'VE COME FOR SEEN NOT OPEN TO
DISCUSSION THE DIS [inaudible]
ANY MEMBERS [inaudible]
MS FREEMAN.
WHERE SOCCER FAMILY BUT I CAN
SUPPORT THIS TODAY?
THIS CONCUSSIONS [inaudible]
TO THE IS THERE ROOM.
I THANK YOU THANKS THE MEMBER
FOR BRINGING IT UP AND THANKS
FOR THE WITNESSES FOR BEING HERE
JUST HAVE A QUICK QUESTION ABOUT.
HOW DOES THE PROCESS WORK WHO --
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY BUT I JUST WANT TO HAVE A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF WHO'S
ABLE [inaudible]
TO HOLD -- THE ORGANIZATION
ACCOUNTABLE.
IS JUST GOING TO BE BASED ON
LAWSUITS.
OR IS THERE A BODY THAT IS GOING
TO HAVE OVERSIGHT.
SO I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION --
SO THIS BILL HAS BEEN MODELED
AFTER -- THREE OTHER BILLS -- AB
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN AND A. B. -- TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED SO IN IN IN ALL
THREE OF THOSE BILLS -- THERE
THERE WAS NO FORMAL GOVERNING
BODY THERE'S NO OVERSIGHT BODY
IN ANY OF THOSE BILLS WE CARRY
THAT LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION INTO
INTO THIS -- WITHIN FURTHER
ADDED WHAT I WOULD CALL A SELF
GOVERNING DESIGN IN IN THE BILL
SO THERE'S A THERE'S A STATUTE
THERE THAT REQUIRES -- THE LEAKS
TO DECLARE THEIR COMPLIANCE WITH
AB.
ONE A PUBLICLY WITH LANCE BEFORE
YOU GO ON LET ME.
FROM WHAT I RECALL CIF WAS
INVOLVED IN THE PREVIOUS
ITERATIONS OF THE BILLS SO SO SO
IT'S AYE AYE.
CIF IS THE THE HIGH SCHOOLS.
I'M SORRY SO THE THOSE DOES
OTHER THREE BILLS HAVE A PIC
ABILITY TO THE THE THE AD CODE
IN THE EDUCATIONAL CONSTRUCTS.
BUT ALSO BEYOND THAT IN INTO --
CLUBS.
SO THE THE DESIGN THAT WE HAVE
IS THAT IT'S A SELF -- GOVERNING
SITUATION BETWEEN PARENTS AND
THE ASSOCIATIONS WHERE THE IF
THE IF THE ASSOCIATIONS ARE
REQUIRED THE FOOTBALL LEAGUES
ASSOCIATIONS ARE REQUIRED TO
STATE THEIR COMPLIANCE.
WITH THE WITH AB ONE AND THE
PARENTS WILL THEN HOLD THOSE --
THOSE LEAKS ACCOUNTABLE AND IF
THE IF THE PARENT DOESN'T IF THE
LEAGUE ISN'T IS NOT COMPLYING
WITH AB ONE THE PARENT CAN MOVE
THEIR CHILD TO ANOTHER TEAM
[inaudible]
THAT IS.
MISSION -- SOFTENS A TO A
QUESTION MARK YEAH I ALREADY
KNOW SUPPORTER OF THE MANAGER --
JUST THE FOR THE PROTECTION OF
LAW NO YOU ITS THE IN THIS IS
SUPPORT [inaudible] FOR CONTACT.
A PRACTICE SO PHONE THE OFF
SEASON AND THE ONLY -- TWO TIMES
AND NOT MORE THAN TWO TIMES A
ONE HOUR EACH SO.
SOUNDS LIKE ARE YOU YOU ARE
ALLOWING IT UP BUT THAT'S A
LIMITING THE PRACTICE TIME AND
NOT SO DURING THE OFFSEASON IS
THAT CORRECT SO -- IT MOSTLY
CRACK I MAKE ONE CLARIFICATION
SO WERE WERE -- LIMITING FULL
CONTACT.
IN SEASON TO NO MORE THAN TWO
TIMES A WEEK. FOR THIRTY NO MORE
THAN THIRTY MINUTES HER PRACTICE
SO THE THIS THIS IS A
PROHIBITING DURING THE OFFSEASON
HOURS ON A WRITE.
OFF SEASON AS WELL.
OFFSEASON OWNS HIS OWN SO
THERE'S THERE'S IN SEASON AN OFF
SEASON YEAH IN SEASON WHICH IS
TYPICALLY -- BAD ABOUT CAMP AND
PRACTICES THROUGH THROUGH THE
WEEK OF GAMES WHICH IS TYPICALLY
IN THE FALL -- THAT'S THE IN
SEASON PERIOD PRACTICE FULL
CONTACT IS LIMITED TO TWO TIMES
A WEEK AT THIRTY MINUTES PER
PRACTICE.
THAT'S THE MOST STRINGENT
GUIDELINES IN THE COUNTRY -- AND
THEN THERE'S NO CONTACT ALLOWED
IN THE OFF SEASON SO YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO PLAY YEAR ROUND
TACKLE FOOTBALL.
I SEE SO YOU ARE TRYING TO
REDUCE THE PROBABILITY OF LET'S
SEE VIA ACCIDENTS SELF.
FOR ALLOWING FOR CONTACT US
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
CORRECT RIGHT NOW FACILITIES
OTHER LEAGUES THEY CAN HIT FIVE
DAYS A WEEK HIGH SCHOOLS
RESTRICTED TO TWICE A WEEK FOR
NINETY MINUTES SO THIS
DEFINITELY COMPRESSES IT.
MAKES A MUCH SAFER THOSE FOR
THOSE YOUNG ATHLETES AS WITH
MOST JUDGES IN THE COUNTRY.
SOME COACHES WAIT FIVE DAYS A
WEEK IT JUST DEPENDS ON THE
COACHING LEVEL THIS REGULATES IT
YEAH -- OKAY I'M I'M NOT A NEXT
BUT IN FOOTBALL GAMES SO HOW.
IN ALL NEGATIVE -- IMPACTS --
THEY WOULD HAVE TO HAVE
COLLISION NOT BUT THE STEER YOU
ARE ALLOWING ABOUT THE
MINIMIZING THE FOR CONTACT OUT
OF PURE YET THE WEATHER
DISTORTED.
IMPROVE THAT THEIR SAFETY
OBVIOUSLY TO IT WE OUR OWN SELF
BUT IT WHEN THEY GROW INTO A
HIGH SCHOOL OR AND OF COLLEGE
OFF.
EVEN -- PROFESSIONAL LEVEL.
I MEAN THEY I THOUGHT SOME FACT
OF LIFE -- FOOTBALL IS SELF FOR
CONTACT US SO WHEN YOU TRY TO
LIMIT THAT THE WAY THAT THEY
WILL BE FULLY TRAINED. FOR THE
LATER NOT A LIFE I DON'T KNOW SO
THAT SO THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
SO I IN IN ADDITION TO MY ROLE
WITH THE ALLIANCE I'VE BEEN --
AFFILIATED WITH -- FOOTBALL FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS AND POP WARNER
YOUTH FOOTBALL FOR THIRTEEN OF
THOSE YEARS -- I RUN A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE PLAYER LEAGUE I'M
SORRY SO STATION AND LARKSPUR
CALIFORNIA -- I CAN TELL YOU
RIGHT NOW FOR YEARS WE'VE BEEN
PRACTICING CONTACT TWICE A WEEK
AT TWENTY MINUTES.
I'M SO WITH THE ACTUAL PRACTICE
IS IS IS IS ACTUALLY LESS AND
WE'RE WE'RE VERY WE'RE VERY
COMPETITIVE TEAM -- WE PLAY VERY
SMART FOOTBALL WE'RE NOT THE
BIGGEST WE'RE NOT THE STRONGEST
WE JUST PLAY VERY VERY SMART
INTELLIGENT -- AND WE WOULD
PREPARE THE KIDS WELL SO --
THIRTY MINUTES TWICE A WEEK IS --
PLENTY OF TIME.
IT CO INC COMBINED WITH --
ANOTHER -- REQUIREMENT OF THE
BILL IS THE COACHES EVERY COACH
OF EVERY FOOTBALL TEAM IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS REQUIRED
TO GET CERTIFIED EVERY YEAR AND
BLOCKING AND TACKLING TECHNIQUES
THAT MINIMIZE THAT IMPLY.
SO THIS COMBINATION OF EDUCATION
TRAINING REDUCTION OF OF OF
CONTACT TIME THESE ARE ALL LOT
OF THE BEST PRACTICES THAT ARE
THAT EXIST THAT WERE CODIFYING.
I SEE.
OKAY ANOTHER TEST OF SALT -- IS
THAT THEY EAT R. I'M SURE HE
FOOTBALL INDUSTRY I OR TRY TO
COME UP WITH THE HELLO MATT SAID
THAT WOULD PROTECT THE BRAINS TO
WHATEVER.
BUT THOUGH FROM MY THE KNOWLEDGE
IS THAT THE WHATEVER SOFT.
PAD THIS -- INSIDE.
OF THE HELMET.
I ONE THIRTY FIVE THERE IS ANY --
ONE TRYING TO DEVELOP BY.
THE EXTERNAL IMPACT IS DOUBLE
HARD TO YOU KNOW GET.
A FACE TO FACE UP OUR HEARTS OF
HIS CONTACT THAT THAT WORD WILL
BE -- TO PENETRATE THE IMPACT.
IF DOES SELF ABSORBED OVER
MATERIAL X. TONE ON THE IN A
SOFT.
THAT THAT MAY BE AN IDEA.
YEAH THAT THERE'S THERE'S BEEN
SIGNIFICANT ADVANCEMENTS IN THE
TECHNOLOGY OF TACKLE FOOTBALL
PARTICULAR IN THE PAST FIVE TO
TEN YEARS -- SO WE'VE MET WITH
MULTIPLE HELMET PROVIDERS -- THE
THE DESIGN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
ABOUT A SOFTER EXTERNAL SHALL
YES IS REALLY A BODY BY A
COMPANY CALLED VICES OUT OF
SEATTLE.
WASHINGTON WHERE THEY HAVE A
THEY'VE THEY'VE PUT FORWARD THIS
YEAR USED TACKLE FOOTBALL HELMET --
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED FOR YOU
THAT HAS A SOFT.
S. HAS AN OUTER SHELL THAT
ACTUALLY GIVES WAY YES ENOUGH
ISN'T A HARD ABSOLUTELY SHELL.
JUNGLE SO WHERE YOU HAVE LIKE A
SHOCK ABSORBER RIGHT.
AND VIRGINIA TECH -- TESTS
HELMETS OF EVERY YEAR TO CERTIFY
THEM AND PUT THEM ON A FIVE STAR
SCALE AND PROVIDES RATINGS OF
WHAT THE BEST HOW MUCH ARE.
SO THERE THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT --
ADVANCEMENTS IN IN THAT INDUSTRY
AND THERE'S EVEN THERE'S OTHER
ORGANIZATION -- LIGHT HELMETS
OUT OF SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA THAT
HAS THE LIGHT IS COMING ON THE
MARKET.
AND THE DATE SO THERE AND THAT
THAT HOME IS BASED UPON MILITARY
AND AEROSPACE THE TECHNOLOGY.
SO THERE'S LOTS OF MANAGEMENT
AND AND FRANKLY LIGHT HELMETS --
THE LIGHTER HELMET FOR USED IS A
VERY INTERESTING OPTION BECAUSE
OF THE STRENGTH OF THE NECK.
AND THE ABILITY TO NOT HAVE TO
HAVE A THREE AND A HALF POUND
HELMET THEIR HOME AND I THINK IS
TWO POINT. TWO POINT THREE
POUNDS -- SO THERE'S LOTS OF
DIFFERENT CHOICES FOR KIDS IN
AND BASED UPON THE KIND OF
PLAYER THE POSITION SOME HELMETS
MIGHT BE MORE APPROPRIATE.
THAN OTHERS.
SO GLAD TO HEAR THAT --
INDUSTRIES -- DOING THAT KIND OF
A RESEARCH AND YOU KNOW IT IT IT
BRINGS UP A GREAT POINT ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY WE FOUND OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOOTBALL LINES IS
THERE'S A LOT OF DEVELOPMENT IN
THE COMMERCIAL SPACE.
REGARDING -- FOOTBALL AND SO
WE'RE TRYING TO SHEPHERD THAT
DOWN A PATH TO HELP
ORGANISATIONS MAKE THE BEST
POSSIBLE CHOICES.
YEAH IF AND WHEN THEY HAVE A
VERY -- SAFE I HAVE MET THAN YOU
CAN WE CAN YOU KNOW UNDO THIS
REGULATION.
THERE'S THERE'S NO REPLACEMENT
THERE'S NO REPLACEMENT FOR GREAT
TECHNIQUE AND KEEP THE HEAD OUT
OF THE GAME AND ACTUALLY THE
BEST TECHNIQUE THE BEST
PERFORMANCE OF FOOTBALL PLAYERS.
THE BILL USED AHEAD WHICH IS
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT WHEN I
PLATING AND AND AND GRADE SCHOOL
HIGH SCHOOL COLLEGE IT'S A
COMPLETE DIFFERENT GAME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER COOPER.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD -- LAST YEAR WILL.
THIS COMMITTEE IS WORKING. FOR A
VERY VERY SIMILAR BILL LIKE
YOURS -- WE'RE TRYING -- TO
WORKING WITH SOME OTHER MEMBERS.
BUT A BECAUSE IT BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION THAT.
A LOT OF THE HEAD INJURIES.
THAT DOESN'T REALLY NOT
NECESSARILY HOW OFTEN IN MEDIA A
FACT BUT WHEN THEY GROW TO A
OLDER AGE.
AND OR SOME A STUDY SHOWS THAT --
THE INCREASING THE THE HEAD
TRAUMA AND ALSO BECAUSE THE KIDS
OR TO USE.
THEIR BRAINS ARE NOT FULLY
DEVELOPED THERE ARE MORE --
VULNERABLE -- TO TO TO TO TO
JUST KIND OF THE THE CUT REPEAT
IT -- HEAD TRAUMA SO -- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS IS -- I WOULD DEFINITELY
ASK MY SUPPORT TOUR.
AND YOU JUST BE THE WAY TO WORK
AB ONE THE FIRST BILL INTRODUCED
IN THE HOUSE.
A GOOD THIS YEAR SO -- WITH
STRAT -- BUT ON SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AB ONE COOPER DE PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR KANSEN CHU HI
KANSEN CHU BY DEEP.
DEEP HI DAVID CHIU.
DAVID CHIU AYE CHOI.
CHOI NINE FRIEDMAN.
I MISS ARIAN.
IS ARIANNA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
.
MISTER GALLAGHER IS IN THE HOUSE
2% A. B. SO. SIXTEEN ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LABOR
SORRY I'M RUNNING LATE HERE AT
THE CHAIR OF ELECTIONS COMMITTEE --
TO JUST GOT DONE DOING THAT AND
CAME RIGHT DOWN HERE I'M PROUD
TO PRESENT A. B. -- THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN NO CALIFORNIA WE PRIDE
OURSELVES ON BEING A LEADER WHEN
IT COMES TO FREE SPEECH.
WITH THAT IN MIND I BELIEVE THAT
THE STATE SHOULD HAVE POLICIES
THAT ENCOURAGE SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES TO ALLOW FREE SPEECH.
ON THOSE WHO USE THEIR PLATFORMS
I NO MATTER WHAT THEIR POLITICAL
VIEWS OR AFFILIATIONS MIGHT BE
AB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN TO PROHIBIT
ANY PERSON WHO OPERATES.
A SOCIAL MEDIA INTERNET WEBSITE --
IN CALIFORNIA FROM REMOVING OR
MANIPULATING CONTENT ON THE
PURELY ON THE BASIS OF POLITICAL
AFFILIATION.
LET ME BE VERY CLEAR THEY WOULD
STILL BE ABLE TO BLOCK.
HATE SPEECH THERE WOULD STILL BE
ABLE TO BLOCK THE OBSCENITY --
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO BLOCK --
INCITEMENT TO VIOLENCE -- ALL
THOSE THINGS YOU KNOW ARE ARE
PROTECTED THEIR FLOW.
OUR FIRST AMENDMENT CASE LAW
MAKES VERY CLEAR THOSE THINGS
CAN BE BANNED AND CAN BE BLOCKED --
AND THEY WOULD CONTINUE TO BE
THIS THIS BILL ALSO.
ALLOWS THE SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES TO ESTABLISH THEIR OWN
TERMS AND CONDITIONS UP FRONT
AND SAY LOOK WE WILL BLOCK
CONTENT.
MAYBE THEY WANT TO SAY HEY LOOK
WE ARE A CONSERVATIVE SIDE ONLY
FOR EXAMPLE AND WE'RE ONLY GONNA.
ALLOW CONSERVATIVE VIEW POINTS
TO BE EXPRESSED ON ON THIS --
WEBSITE -- OR MAYBE THEY WANT TO
SAY WE ARE OF YOU KNOW
PROGRESSIVES ONLY.
WELL WEBSITE AND AN ESTABLISHED
THAT CLEARLY ON THEIR TERMS AND
CONDITIONS WE WE WILL NOT POST --
YOU KNOW CERTAIN THINGS -- YOU
KNOW THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
COULD BE DONE IF IF THAT WAS
CLEARLY WITHIN THEIR TERMS -- IN
CONDITIONS -- BUT WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE ALTERNATELY IS
IT LOOK THESE PLATFORMS NOW
BECOME -- YOU KNOW PLACES WHERE
WE ARE DEBATING YOU KNOW ISSUES
OF PUBLIC CONCERN WE WERE HAVING
DISCUSSIONS WHERE WHERE.
WE AS CANDIDATES WERE ELECTION
HEARING.
ON THESE WEBSITES TO GET
INFORMATION OUT IN THE VIEW
POINTS OUT -- AND I THINK ONE OF
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE --
CURRENTLY IN OUR SOCIETY IS
WE'VE WE HAVE WE HAVE BEGIN THE
ISOLATE OURSELVES SO MUCH SO.
THAT WE DON'T WANT TO HEAR.
OTHER VIEW POINTS AND WE DON'T
HEAR OTHER VIEW POINTS AND
THAT'S PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE IN A
IN A CIVIL SOCIETY.
IN ORDER FOR TO BE HEALTHY WE
NEED TO HEAR LOTS OF DIFFERENT
VIEWPOINTS -- THIS WAS SORT OF
ON I THINK THIS WAS HIGHLIGHTED
THE MULLER REPORT.
ACTUALLY WHERE THE RUSSIAN -- ME
OF THE RUSSIAN THE INTERESTS
THAT WERE INTERFERE ELECTIONS
THEY WERE CREATING.
SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTS. TO
SPECIFICALLY GO TO AREA STE TO
SPECIFICALLY TARGET LIKE
ISOLATED GROUPS TEA PARTY.
BLACK LIVES MATTER -- YOU KNOW
AND IN DIFFERENT THEY WERE YOU
KNOW THEY WERE TRYING TO
BASICALLY TARGET IN SIGHT THOSE
GROUPS TO GET ANGRY ABOUT AN
ISSUE IN ORDER TO SOW DISCORD --
AND I THINK WHEN WHEN WE WHEN WE
ALLOW OURSELVES BECOME MORE
ISOLATED THIS IS BEEN FURTHER
EXACERBATED BUT WE KNOW THAT
FACEBOOK ACTUALLY STARTED
ALGORITHM.
WHERE YOU WOULD GET MORE OF THE
CONTENT THAT WE THINK YOU LIKE --
HEY AND THE RESULT OF THAT IS
THAT YOU START GETTING ONLY VIEW
POINTS THAT THEY THINK YOU LIKE
IF YOU'RE CONSERVATIVE YOU'RE
ONLY GOING TO GET CONSERVATIVE
VIEWPOINT SEVERE.
PROGRESSIVE YOU'RE ONLY GOING TO
GET THOSE VIEWPOINTS I THINK
THAT CONTINUES.
TO REALLY MORE DIVIDE US AN
ISOLATED US.
RATHER THAN DO WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE WHICH IS ALLOW FOR THAT
FREE FLOW OF DEBATE AND
DISCUSSION -- I LEARN MORE.
BY HEARING FROM PEOPLE FROM
OTHER VIEWPOINTS MIA.
AS SAID IN LAST COMMITTEE IN --
MY AUNT AND MY ENTIRE ADULT LIFE
I'VE BEEN SURROUNDED BY LIBERALS
YOU KNOW WHAT TO UC BERKELEY.
UC DAVIS -- NHà NOT NOT NOW I'M
IN IN IN THIS BODY.
I THINK IT'S SAFE TO SAY I'M
PROBABLY A A MINORITY VIEWPOINT --
NOT ALWAYS BUT ON A LOT ISSUES.
BUT I THINK WE GAIN FROM HEARING
EACH OTHER'S PERSPECTIVES. FOR
ME MAY BE HEARING FROM A RURAL
PERSPECTIVE -- YOU KNOW FROM
ISSUES RELATED TO WATER AND HOW
THAT AFFECTS OUR AREA IN THE
NORTH.
LEARNING FROM MY OF MY COLLEAGUE
THE CHAIRMAN ABOUT ISSUES THAT
AFFECT SAN JOSE AND AND HOUSING
ISSUES AND TRANSPORTATION ISSUES.
THIS IS REALLY TRYING TO ENSURE
THAT WE KEEP THAT KIND OF FREE
FLOW OF DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
OUR SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS WHERE
THERE WHERE THEY HAVE BECOME --
THESE PLACES WHERE WE HAVE AND
WE NEED TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT HOW WE MOVE FORWARD AS A
COUNTRY -- YOU KNOW IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND AS A STATE.
SO THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE THE THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU
HAVE ANY WITNESSES. TO A SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KEVIN
MCKINLEY.
AND THE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR INTERNET
SO SHE XIN WHICH REPRESENTS OVER
FORTY OF THE WORLD'S LEADING
INTERNET COMPANIES.
THE INTERNET HAS BECOME WHAT IT
IS TODAY THANKS TO THE FACT THAT
IT'S FREE OPEN IN ACCEPTING OF
YOU POINTS AFFILIATIONS FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD.
PEOPLE FROM EVERY POLITICAL WALK
OF LIFE CONFINED COMMUNITIES IN
CONTENT THAT INTEREST THEM.
IN POLITICAL INTERNET PLATFORMS
ENABLE EVERYONE TO LEARN.
AND SHARE AND DEBATED FIRST IF
USING TOPICS.
HOWEVER THIS BILLS BASED ON
FLAWED PREMISE.
THAT MODERATION DECISIONS ARE
BASED ON POLITICAL VIEWPOINTS
THEY'RE NOT BASED ON POLITICAL
VIEWPOINTS.
ONLINE PLATFORMS AND FORCE
COMMUNITY STANDARDS WHICH ALLOW
USERS TO FEEL SAFE SECURE BOTH
ONLINE AND OFF.
DID EXTENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER ENVISIONS INTERNET
PLATFORMS LISTING OUT.
VARIETIES OF POLITICAL SPEECH
THAT ARE UNACCEPTABLE ON THE
PLATFORM IT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT THE WAY THAT
MODERATION DECISIONS ARE MADE
TODAY.
THE PLAN FOR SEDATE REMOVE
CONTENT THE POSES A THREAT OF
HARM OR PUBLIC SAFETY.
OR PROMOTES HATRED HATRED%
VIOLENCE -- AGAINST CERTAIN
GROUPS SO ALLEGATIONS THE
PLATFORMS ENGAGE AND POLITICALLY
BIASED MODERATING IS NOT CORRECT.
OR THAT PRACTICES LIKE SHADOW
BANNING -- CONSERVATIVES ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
IS ALSO NOT CORRECT SO TO THE
EXTENT THIS BILL WILL IMPEDE
PLATFORMS ABILITY TO MODERATE
YOU KNOW TROLL SPREADING
ELECTION MISINFORMATION.
OR VIDEOS CLAIMING THAT THINGS
LIKE SANDY HOAX WERE A HOAX WE
FIND IT UNACCEPTABLE -- WE THINK
THAT THIS BILL WILL ALLOW BAD
ACTORS TO CLAIM THAT THEY'RE
BEING CENSORED FOR POLITICAL
REASONS WHEN IN FACT OF BEING
BANNED OR MODERATED FOR OTHER
REASONS -- AND NOT BEING BASED
ON YOU KNOW THE SENSOR BASED ON
POLITICAL VIEWPOINT AT ALL.
SO PEOPLE ARE YOU USE THESE
PLATFORMS TO FIND CONTENT THEY
LIKE SOME USERS ONE PARTICULAR
CONTENT.
SOME USERS ASK PLATFORMS NOT
SHOW THE CONTENT THEY FIND
OBJECTIONABLE.
AND THIS BILL WOULD UNDERMINE
PLATFORMS TOOLS TO SERVE THE
USERS -- SO AGAIN WE LOOK AT
THIS BILL IS IMPEDING MODERATION
AND ALLOWING.
BAD ACTORS ON SOCIAL MEDIA TO
HAVE ANOTHER AVENUE FOR CLAIMING
THAT THEY'RE BEING.
MODERATED THE CONTENTS BEING
SENSOR BASED ON VIEWPOINT.
WHEN THAT'S NOT THE CASE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE DAY US.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
TO WHICH ALL DIFFERENT MISTER
CHOI CHU.
CHU.
CHOI.
HERE IS A POLITICAL VIEWS ARE OF
THAT THAT CONTENT EXCEPT THE S.
A PROVIDED A BY.
SO IN OTHER WORDS SO.
IF THE SET UP.
ORG Z. -- THE PURPOSES SO WE ARE
TRYING -- TO PROMOTE HERE'S THE
RULE OF LAW FOR THE FREEDOM OF
SPEECH IF THE SET UP BY HEY WE
HAVE ALL RIGHT -- TO CAN I IS
SET UP THEIR OWN NON POLITICAL
VIEWS -- IN THEIR EXCEPTION
EXCEPT HERE IN THAT LINE.
ALL THAT AND NOW WE ARE STUCK.
IN THE STORE I MEAN.
THEY THEY CAN THEY CAN INCLUDE
THAT THEY'RE A WHATEVER WE ARE
TRYING.
TO ACCOMPLISH YOUR LIKE A
POLITICAL VIEW-- SO -- THINGS
LIKE THAT -- AND THEN -- THEY WE
HAVE A RIGHT.
TO IN ALL MONITOR POLITICAL
VIEWS OR WHATEVER IF WE DON'T IF
WE DON'T AGREE WITH YOU WITH AND
HOW WE IN ALL.
OF PROTECT THAT THE FREEDOM
FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
ARE THAT THEY CANNOT INCLUDE DOT
IN THAT THE EXCEPTION.
THE EXECUTIVE SEARCH IS RUNNING
QUESTION.
NOW I WAS A TEACHER. TO ORDER
FOR TO THE ALSO YOU WANT TO
ANSWER IT NOW OR ANSWERING YOUR
CLOSING WELL I I THINK WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO -- DOCTOR
CHOI IS IS SAY THAT -- IN
GENERAL WE WANT TO PROVIDE FOR A
FREE FLOW OF IDEAS ON THE SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS -- BUT WE ALSO
WANT TO GET AT THE ALSO OF RIGHT
TO ASSOCIATE.
YOU HAVE THE FREEDOM OF
ASSOCIATION AND SO.
CERTAIN -- WHETHER IT'S MAYBE A
A BLOG PAGE OR OF A PAGE THAT IS
SET UP ON SOCIAL MEDIA -- MAY
SAY LOOK WE ARE A REST OF SITE
WE ONLY WELCOME PROGRESSIVE
DISCUSSION AND YOU POINTS HERE
AND THEY AND THEY STATE THAT
CLEARLY ON THEIR TERMS AND
CONDITIONS.
YOU KNOW THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO DO
THAT BUT THAT'S THE POINT IS PUT
THAT IN YOUR TERMS AND
CONDITIONS UP FRONT SO EVERYBODY
KNOWS THAT'S THE CASE.
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
FACEBOOK'S PLATFORM FOR EGGS I'M
JUST USING FACEBOOK HAS ARE
PROBABLY THE MOST WIDELY USED --
THEY DON'T DO THAT RIGHT THEY
SAY HEY COME ON AND HAVE
CONVERSATIONS THEY DO HAVE TERMS
AND CONDITIONS -- BUT THEY
INVITE EVERYBODY TO COME ON TO
THE PLATFORM AND AND AND EXPRESS
VIEWPOINT SHARE THINGS WITH
THEIR FRIENDS -- AND AND SO IN
THAT CIRCUMSTANCE -- YOU SHOULD
ALLOW THE FREE FLOW OF IDEAS
UNLESS THE ISSUE IS.
AND LOOK AT THINK OUR BILL
ADDRESSES THIS IF THE IF YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT OBSCENITY.
YUP PORNOGRAPHIC IMAGES.
YOU KNOW -- IF YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT INCITEMENT TO VIOLENCE
LIKE CLIMB FOR THE KILLING OF
POLICE OFFICERS FOR EXAMPLE --
OR YOUR YOU YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT --
NO ISSUES INVOLVED WITH -- MISS
SIMPLE MASON RIGHT EXAMPLE THAT
WOULD BE SOMETHING YOU COULD
STILL TAKE DOWN.
BUT YOU CAN'T BLOCK.
THE INFORMATION PURELY BASED ON
ITS POLITICAL CONTENT.
OKAY AS OF RIGHT DIRECTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AB.
APPRECIATE YOU -- EXPLAINING
WE'RE COMING FROM WITH THE BILL
I MUST CALL THE LAST NIGHT AFTER
READ THIS BECAUSE I HAD A LOT OF
QUESTIONS BUT AS SOMEONE WHO'S
DRAFTED ATTRACTED HUNDREDS OF
TERMS AND CONDITIONS -- IN A
PAST LIFE AND AND I HAVE NOT
SEEN TO THE CHALLENGES THAT I
THINK YOU'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS
HERE LET ME STATE AT THE OUTSET
I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU THAT
WE WANT TO FOSTER -- A FREE FLOW
OF COMMUNICATION -- I THINK THE
WHAT I'M WHAT I'M GATHERING IS
THAT YOU'RE SUGGESTING THAT
THERE ARE SOME THERE ARE.
THAT SOMEHOW THE TEAS AND SEE
THE TERMS AND CONDITIONS ARE NOT.
ADEQUATE -- I GUESS THE FIRST
QUESTION I HAVE IS FOR MAJOR
SOCIAL MEDIA SITES THEY ALL HAVE
TERMS AND CONDITIONS RIGHT RED
OKAY SO WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
SOLVE THAT.
BUT YOUR BILL SAYS -- IF YOU'RE
OPERATING A WEBSITE YOU SHOULD
REMOVE OR MEDICALLY CONTENT
UNLESS IS PROVIDED BY THE SOCIAL
MEDIA.
WEBSITES TERMS AND CONDITIONS
BUT YOU DON'T PROVIDE ANY
GUIDANCE OF WHAT NEEDS TO BE IN
THOSE TERMS AND CONDITIONS YOU
SIMPLY SAY YOU LEAVE IT UP TO
THE WEBSITE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
SHOULD BE IN THE CITY'S SEES.
RIGHT RIGHT.
SO IF THERE'S NO GUIDANCE AND
THESE IN OF ALL OF THE COMPANIES
OR TALK ABOUT HAVE TERMS AND
CONDITIONS AND WHAT ARE YOU
SOLVING WITH THIS BILL.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION
I'M JUST TRYING TO REALLY
ESTABLISH THAT LOOK WE DON'T
WANT TO BLOCK.
CONTENT PURELY BASED ON
POLITICAL -- VIEWED THE
POLITICAL VIEWPOINT BRANCH I
THINK IS ALREADY AN ESTABLISHED
PRINCIPLE ANYWAY AND BUT YOU
KNOW BUT STILL LIVE IN WE KNOW%
FROM FIRST MEMBER THAT YOU CAN
BLOCK THINGS THAT OBVIOUSLY ARE
NOT PROTECTED SPEECH.
AS AS YOU ALREADY WENT THROUGH
BUT I'M ALSO YES GIVING YOU KNOW
STILL GIVING -- THESE PRIVATE
COMPANIES AND I THINK THAT'S
WHERE THIS COMING BECAUSE THEY
ARE PRIVATE COMPANY THEY'RE NOT.
THERE ARE NOT THE GOVERNMENT --
HOWEVER THERE WERE IN THIS KIND
OF GRAY ONE WORLD A LITTLE BIT
IN THE SENSE THAT THEY'RE NOT
THE GOVERNMENT BUT WE KNOW THAT
FACEBOOK IS USE A LOT AS AT A
PLATFORM FOR A LOT OF ISSUES A
DISCUSSION.
THEY'RE A MATTER OF PUBLIC
CONCERN I MEAN ALL OF US HAVE
FACEBOOK ACCOUNTS.
WE SEE THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
VERY MUCH A LOT OF POLITICAL
DISCUSSIONS THAT GO ON ON
VARIOUS ISSUES.
THE BILLS THAT WERE RUNNING
AFTER ENTER A SUBJECT TO THOSE
THINGS WHERE PEOPLE ARE GOING
BACK AND FORTH.
ON THE SINK SO THERE IS IT VERY
MUCH HAS BECOME.
SORT OF A BECAUSE I HAD LIMITED
PUBLIC FORUM RIGHT AND SO WE
WANT TO PROTECT THAT WHILE ALSO
GIVING THE PRIVATE COMPANY.
THE ABILITY USE THEIR TERMS AND
CONDITIONS TO STATE OUT RIGHT
FOR EVERYBODY HEY HERE'S HOW
WE'RE GOING TO OPERATE OUR SITE
AND YOU HAVE TO ABIDE BY THOSE
CONDITIONS ARE WE WILL -- YOU
KNOW.
BLOCKING YOUR OR TAKE DOWN YOUR
POST.
WHAT WHAT I'VE SEEN IS THAT --
THE COMPANIES ARE TALKING ABOUT
ALL HAVE VERY CLEARLY LAID OUT
TERMS AND CONDITIONS THERE ARE
MANY MANY LAWYERS AND INTERNAL
FOLKS WITHIN COMPANIES SPENT A
LOT OF TIME FIGURE THIS OUT AND
THEY DO LAID OUT AND I WILL SAY
PERSONALLY FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
I WISH THAT THE COMPANIES THAT A
LITTLE BIT MORE TO ADDRESS THE
HATE SPEECH IN THE VIOLENCE THAT
WE SEE AND I'LL JUST GIVE
EXAMPLES ONE I HAVE PROPOSED PRO
LGBT.
BILLS THE VIOLENTLY HATEFUL AND
HOMOPHOBIC COMMENTS THAT WE GET
ON OUR WEBSITES ARE ARE VERY
INTENSE WHEN I PROPOSED PRO GUN
SAFETY BILLS.
THE SUPPORTERS OF GUN RIGHTS
HAVE BEEN VERY VIOLENTLY AND
VEER AT LADY -- OUTSPOKEN IN
THEIR PERSPECTIVE WHEN I PROPOSE
PRO IMMIGRANT.
LAWS -- ANTI IMMIGRANT FORCES --
DESCEND ON MY FACEBOOK PAGE AND
OTHER PAGES IN A VERY INTENSE
WAY -- AND FROM WHAT I CAN TELL
THERE'S ACTUALLY VERY LITTLE
CENSORSHIP IF NOT NO CENSORSHIP
THAT I'M AWARE OF THAT'S
ACTUALLY HAPPENING ON THE SOCIAL
MEDIA SITES AGAIN I'M JUST.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WHAT
PROBLEM YOU'RE TRYING TO CREATE
A WHAT I'M WORRIED ABOUT IS --
YOU'RE LAYERING ON A RULE THAT
SAYS IF YOU OPERATE A WEBSITE.
YOU CAN'T REMOVE THIS CONTENT
AND LET'S IT'S PROVIDED BY YOUR
THIESSEN SEES BUT THAT'S ALREADY
HAPPENING SO I'M JUST NOT IT TO
ME FEELS LIKE THIS IS JUST
CONFUSING.
WHAT THE STANDARD OUGHT TO BE
FOR FOR THESE COMPANIES AND AND
AGAIN AS SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN A
LOT OF TIME THINKING ABOUT THIS
BUT ALSO INTERACTED WITH A LOT
OF INDIVIDUALS?
WHO ARE TRYING TO FIGURE THIS
OUT I JUST DON'T SEE THAT
HAPPENING AND I'M WORRIED ABOUT
CONFUSING THE ROLE SO I'M
WONDERING IF THE INTERNET
CESSATION KIND OF WHAT YOUR
EXPERIENCES YOU'RE TRYING TO
GRAPPLE WITH THESE ISSUES HAS
BEEN?
YEAH I THINK THE QUESTION AND I
I AGREE THAT WE NEED TO DO A
BETTER JOB OF MODERATING CONTENT
I MEAN I THINK WE'RE HEARING
THAT.
UNIVERSALLY THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY AND INTERNET ASSOCIATION
MEMBERS IN THE BIG INTERNET
PLATFORMS ARE TRYING TO DO
BETTER MODERATING CONTENT SO I
HEAR YOU ON THAT AND WE TOTALLY
AGREE WITH YOU -- FUNDAMENTALLY
THE PLATFORMS DO NOT MODERATE
BASED ON POLITICAL VIEWPOINT
THEY MODERATE BASED ON HATE
SPEECH INCITEMENT ETCETERA.
SO THAT'S NOT GONNA CHANGE WITH
THIS BILL THIS BILL DOESN'T
ADDRESS THAT OR MAKE IT BETTER.
BUT WHAT IT DOES IS IT GIVES.
FOLKS WHO ARE MODERATED OR
CENSORED AN AVENUE TO POINT SEE
THIS IS ACTUALLY BASED ON
POLITICAL VIEWPOINT.
AND ONE PERSON HATE SPEECH MAYBE
ANOTHER PERSON'S POLITICAL
VIEWPOINT RIGHT I MEAN.
WE SEE THAT A LOT NGUYEN.
YOU KNOW COMMENTATORS WHO ARE
YOU KNOW PERPETRATING YOU KNOW
HOAX VIDEOS ETCETERA DO GET
SENSORS SAYING IT'S BECAUSE I'M
CONSERVATIVE IT'S NOT BECAUSE
THE CONTENT.
SO WE THINK THIS ACTUALLY
DOESN'T REMEDY THE SITUATION --
CONTENT STILL TO BE MODERATED
BASED ON EXISTING TERMS OF
SERVICE AND WHAT IT'S GOING TO
DO IS CREATE FURTHER DIVISION BY
GIVING -- FOLKS AN INCORRECT
VIEW TO POINT TO A SINGER
MODERATING ME BASED ON POLITICAL
VIEWPOINT LOOK AT THE
RECOGNITION CALIFORNIA LAW YOU
CAN'T DO THAT.
AND WE'RE STILL MODERATING NEED
DO A BETTER JOB OF CLEANING UP
THE PLATFORMS TO ADDRESS THE
THINGS THAT YOU IDENTIFIED.
I AM HAPPY TO CONTINUE ENGAGE IN
THE CONVERSATION BUT BUT I'M
JUST WORRIED THAT WE'RE OR
ACTUALLY MAKING THINGS MORE
CONFUSING FOR STANDARDS AS
OPPOSED TO LESS AND SO FOR THAT
I WON'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY BUT AGAIN WE SHOULD
WE ALL SHARE THE GOAL OF MAKING.
SURE THAT THERE IS A FREE FLOW
OF INFORMATION I JUST WANT THAT
TO BE DONE AS CLEARLY AS
POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU MISTER OF THIS AREA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THIS IS.
TYPE I WASN'T GOING TO BRING
THIS UP.
BECAUSE I HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE
TO FOLLOW UP WITH THE SOCIAL
MEDIA -- COMPANY THAT ACTUALLY
BART THIS SPEECH BUT THIS IS NOT
A QUESTION IT'S MORE OF A
COMMENT AND SINCE IT JUST
HAPPENED RECENTLY AS OF APRIL.
TWENTY SEVEN I THOUGHT I JUST
RAISE IT AT THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING AND THEN I'LL DO MY DUE
DILIGENCE OF FOLLOWING UP.
ALSO WITH THE WITH I DON'T EVEN
WANT TO MENTION THE NAME OF THE
COMPANY THE SOCIAL MEDIA
INVOLVED HERE.
BUT A FRIEND OF MINE WHO POSTED
ABOUT HER GRANDMOTHER'S PLIGHT
IN SURVIVING THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE -- THE POST WAS LABELED
AS HATE SPEECH AND REMOVED. TO
HAVE THIS IS THE COUNTER OF WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT EVEN.
WHAT EVEN IS?
WHAT EVEN IS CONSIDERED HATE
SPEECH -- HIS EIGHT I DON'T
THINK THIS WOULD OF BEEN LABELED
AS SUCH.
IT'S A IT'S A THREE PARAGRAPH --
COMMENT TALKING ABOUT THE
NEAREST RELIEF THE REFUGEE
STATUS -- AND HOW SHE'S BEEN
ABLE TO THRIVE BECAUSE OF HER
GRANDMOTHER'S PERSEVERANCE -- I
DON'T KNOW WHAT ABOUT THAT AND I
DON'T WANNA READ THROUGH THIS
MISTER CHARM HAPPY TO PROVIDE A
PHOTOCOPY OF THIS.
BUT THIS WAS JUST ONE OF THE
MOST I'VE SEEN THINGS LIKE THIS
HAPPEN BEFORE WAIT LEAVES YOU
SCRATCHING YOUR HEAD THINKING
WHAT WAS THE HATE SPEECH IN THIS.
CONTENT -- SO.
I ALMOST FEEL ON ON ANOTHER AND
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
DEFINITION OF WHAT IS CONSIDERED.
WHAT WHAT'S THE STANDARD?
SO THAT ARBITRARILY THINGS LIKE
THIS THAT ARE TALKING ABOUT AN
INDIVIDUAL'S HISTORY AND PLATE.
OF BECAUSE THIS JUST RAISES A
LOT OF OTHER QUESTIONS OF WHY IS
THIS BEING MONITORED.
ON WHOSE BEHALF WHOSE INTEREST
AND WHY WOULD SOMETHING LIKE
THIS IS SO WELL WRITTEN SO WELL
DOCUMENTED BE CONSIDERED HATE
SPEECH.
SO -- AGAIN THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT I NEED TO DO MY DUE
DILIGENCE ON BUT GIVEN THE
CONTEXT OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
BRING UP BECAUSE YOU ALMOST WANT
TO HAVE EVEN MORE CLARITY ON
KNOWING WHAT WILL BE CONSIDERED
AS HATE SPEECH SO THAT.
SOMETHING LIKE THIS DOESN'T FALL
INTO THAT CATEGORY -- AND I'M
HAPPY TO PROVIDE THIS TO MISTER
CHAIR AND TO THE MEMBERS AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
MS FREEMAN.
ART SO -- I APPRECIATE YOUR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE THIS DISCUSSION AND I
LIKE MR CHIU VERY MUCH -- AGREE
WITH YOUR UNDERLYING CONCEPT
THAT.
WE NEED TO BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT --
ENTER SHIP OF POLITICAL VIEWS --
BUT IF IT MAKES YOU FEEL ANY
BETTER IF YOU TALK TO A LOT OF
THE PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT THEY
WOULD SAY THAT THIS IS HAPPENING
A LOT MORE TO THE LEFT.
THEN TO THE RIGHT AND I'VE GOT A
LOT OF YOUR FAR LEFT ACTIVISM MY
DISTRICT TO CONSTANTLY GET
KICKED OFF OF VARIOUS SOCIAL
MEDIA SITES AND THEN KIND OF
FIND A WAY TO GET BACK IN AND
GET KICKED OFF AGAIN -- I
HAVEN'T DELVED INTO EXACTLY WHY
BUT IT SEEMS TO BE AN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY -- PROBLEM SO -- IF
IT MAKES YOU FEEL BETTER THAT
IT'S NOT JUST FOLKS THAT ARE ON
THE RIGHT SIDE OF THE SPECTRUM I
CAN GUARANTEE YOU YOU'LL HEAR A
LOT OF THESE COMPLAINTS FROM
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM.
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT IT'S YOU
THE THE PROBLEM THAT I SEE WITH
SOCIAL MEDIA GOES SO MUCH DEEPER
AND HAS SO MUCH MORE TO DO WITH
THEIR ALGORITHMS.
HELP CONTENTS FILTERED AND FED
BACK TO PEOPLE -- CREATING --
KIND OF ECHO CHAMBERS OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE ONLY BE EXPOSED TO THEIR
OWN VIEWS WHICH IS NOT A
QUESTION OF CENSORSHIP IT'S A
QUESTION OF A EYES AND
ALGORITHMS AND HOW THEY CHOOSE.
TO FEED CONTENT TO PEOPLE WHICH
THIS BILL DOESN'T YOU KNOW
ADDRESSING WHICH IS YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING THAT THERE I
WOULD HOPE OR THINKING ABOUT AT
THIS POINT [inaudible]
AND I THINK RIGHT NOW IT'S A YOU
KNOW IT'S A RELATIVELY NEW
PHENOMENON.
AND THEY'RE DEALING WITH THEIR
ISSUES OF BOTS AND
MISINFORMATION CAMPAIGNS AND
THAT.
LACK OF TRANSPARENCY ABOUT WHO'S
BEHIND ACCOUNTS THAT THEN START
TO SHAPE OPINIONS AND HOW THAT
ENDS UP THROUGH THEIR OWN PAID
ADVERTISING BECOME EVEN BECOMING
EVEN MORE AMPLIFIED.
AND THEY HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO
DO BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
SERIOUS PROBLEMS WITH THESE WITH
A LOT OF THE SOCIAL MEDIA SITES.
YOU KNOW VERY DEEPLY CONCERNING
PROBLEMS WITH SITES LIKE
FACEBOOK.
AND SO I APPRECIATE YOU KNOW
YOUR TIME TO JUMP INTO A BUT I
THINK THAT WHAT WHAT THEY NEED.
IS A MUCH MORE COMPREHENSIVE
KIND OF DECONSTRUCTION OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND WAYS OF DEALING
WITH IT AND I DO THINK THAT THIS
BILL YOU KNOW WHILE I I AGREE
VERY WELL INTENTIONED I DON'T
KNOW THAT IT REALLY HELPS MOVE
THAT.
EFFORT FORWARD IN THE WAY THAT
IT NEEDS TO BECAUSE IT'S SUCH A
BIGGER [inaudible]
ISSUE THEN.
YOU KNOW WHETHER THEY'RE
CENSORING PARTICULAR POLITICAL
VIEWS WHICH THEY MAY OR MAY NOT
BE BUT EVEN IF THEY WEREN'T AND
I WILL TAKE HIM AT FACE VALUE
THAT THEY'RE NOT.
THERE'S STILL STUFF THAT'S THAT
IS GOING SIDEWAYS HERE THAT'S
THAT'S LEADING AND AND IN TERMS
OF SUCH AS A BY I HAVE A GUN
BILL RIGHT NOW.
THERE'S THE VERY THINLY VEILED
VIOLENT THREATS ON MY OFFICIAL
PAGE THAT.
NO ONE'S TAKING DOWN I'M NOT
GONNA YOU KNOW REPORT IT MYSELF
BUT I IF IF THAT KIND OF CONTENT
WAS ROUTINELY BEING CENSORED WE
WOULDN'T BE SEEING THESE POSTS
POPPING UP LIKE WE ARE -- AND
THEN THE SITUATION THAT MISTER
NAZARIAN DESCRIBES YOU KNOW VERY
TROUBLING AS WELL YOU KNOW WHO
GETS TO FLAG THESE AND WHO'S
MAKING THOSE DECISIONS AND UNDER
WHAT SET OF CRITERIA SO.
I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS TODAY I
EVEN THOUGH I AGREE WITH THE
PHILOSOPHY OF WHAT'S BEHIND IT I
JUST THINK THAT THIS IS GOING TO
NEED TO BE A MUCH MORE
COMPREHENSIVE EFFORT AND HAPPY
TO WORK WITH ANYBODY.
YOU KNOW WHO WANTS TO TO BRING
THAT FORWARD INCLUDING THE SITES
THEMSELVES AND I KNOW THAT
THEY'RE ENGAGED IN THAT ON THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
BUT YOU KNOW THEY MAY VERY WELL
SEE MORE EFFORTS LIKE THIS
COMING FROM CALIFORNIA AS WE SEE
MORE REAL HARM.
BEING INFLICTED ON THE COMMUNITY --
THE FACT THAT I HAVE A STAFFER
WHO WATCHED OVER AND OVER YOU
KNOW WATCHED.
THE MASSACRE THAT JUST HAPPENED
YOU KNOW -- ACROSS THE OCEAN
THAT CAME FROM FACEBOOK IS
DEEPLY TROUBLING I MYSELF HAVE
SEEN CONTENT POP UP BUT I WILL
SAY A LOT LESS LATELY BUT
CONTENT THROUGH A FEED.
OUR OF EXECUTIONS YOU KNOW --
USED TO HAPPEN A LOT MORE BUT
JUST REALLY SHOCKING STUFF AND
IT CAN'T JUST BE THE WILD WEST
OUT THERE SO.
THANKS FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
I'M I'M SORRY I CAN'T SUPPORT
TODAY.
YES I HAVE A QUESTION -- OF THE
GALLAGHER THE THE WAY THAT THAT
I I READ THE SUMMARY OF OF YOUR
BILL I WAS DRAFTED BY THE
CONSULTANT. ONE OF THE THING THE
YOU'RE ONE OF THE THINGS YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO IS.
IS TO NOT.
ALLOW.
OF THE SITE LIKE FACEBOOK OR
INSTAGRAM.
OF FILTER OUT WHAT THEY THINK I
WANT TO SEE CHAU SUITS SO FOR
EXAMPLE.
IF IF I GO ON FACEBOOK AND I DO
A LOT OF SEARCHES ON VIDEO ON
LIKE THREE FOODS A BARBECUE.
AFTER ABOUT A WEEK OR SO.
I WAS GONNA START SEEING THAT
LOT BECAUSE FACEBOOK.
ASSUME THAT THAT'S ALL I WANT TO
SEE -- SO YOU WHAT WHAT YOUR
BILL IS TRYING TO DO IS.
YOU'RE TRYING TO SAY THAT.
HEY FACEBOOK WHICH IS BASED ON
CALIFORNIA -- YOU SHOULDN'T BE
MANIPULATING CONTENT.
OF THE BASE OF THE OVER THE OF
SO IT'S AYE AYES WITH THE YOUR
YOUR GET YOUR TAKE ON THAT THE
SHOULD MANIPULATED BASED PURELY
ON THE POLITICAL VIEW POINT.
OF YOU KNOW OF THAT CONTENT.
RIGHT -- YOU KNOW THERE IS THE
END AND I AGREE THEY NEED TO BE
MODERATING MORE THIS THE HATE
SPEECH THE YOU KNOW THE THE
VIOLENT.
HARASSMENT YOU KNOW THAT'S GOING
ON WHICH THAT'S ALL ABOUT BUT
I'D I THINK MISTER NAZARIAN MADE
A GREAT POINT WHICH THIS
HAPPENED.
TO THIS HAPPENED TO A POLITICAL
CANDIDATE -- IN THIS LAST
ELECTION WHO HIGHLIGHTED IN ONE
OF HER ADDS -- YOU KNOW THE FACT
THAT HER FAMILY HAD ESCAPED
VIETNAM.
AND AND THE COMMUTER ROUGE AND
SHE AND SHE TALKED ABOUT.
THAT EXPERIENCE AND WHAT AND
WHAT TRUTHFULLY.
OCCURRED THERE AND NOW AND THAT
AD WAS BLOCKED -- BY FACEBOOK SO
VERY SOON I MEAN THIS IS WHAT
THIS BILL IS ACTUALLY IS IS
EXACTLY WHAT IS TRYING TO GET AT
THAT YOU CAN'T REALLY BLOCK
SOMETHING BECAUSE YOU DON'T LIKE.
THAT CONTENT THAT IS BEING
BROUGHT FORTH WITH IT.
RIGHT -- NOW YOU KNOW LOOK THERE
YOU KNOW MAYBE I'LL JUST USE
THIS AS MY CLOTHES IF AND LOSSES
OTHER QUESTIONS BUT HE HAS
BECAUSE I DON'T AND I KNOW YOU
GUYS HAVE OTHER BILLS BUT YOU
KNOW -- I AM TRYING TO GET AT
THAT PLACE AND RIGHT NOW MY
VI<c.cyan> MY VEHICLE IS IS -- AS</c>
FAR AS I KNOW THE ONLY -- ONE IN
THE LEGISLATURE THIS TRYING TO
DEAL WITH THIS PROBLEM I'M VERY
OPEN TO MAKING THESE KIND OF
CHANGES TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES
THAT YOU BROUGHT UP.
YOU KNOW TRYING TO MAYBE HAVE
SOME ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE IS ON
ON THE TERMS AND CONDITIONS --
COVERING YOU KNOW THESE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP -- BUT
WE NEED TO DO IT I THINK
EVERYBODY IN HERE AGREES WE NEED
TO DO SOMETHING. TO ADDRESS
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH IN THIS
VERY REAL PROBLEM THAT IS GOING
ON ON ON OUR SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS -- AND IF WE START
GETTING THE PLACE OF WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO BLOCK THINGS REALLY
BASED ON POLITICAL CONTENT I
JUST ASK YOU.
PUT YOURSELF IN THAT POSITION
YOU KNOW WE ALLHAVE FACEBOOK
ACCOUNTS IF YOU POSTED SOMETHING
THAT WAS VERY IMPORTANT TO YOU.
ABOUT A POLITICAL ISSUE AND FOR
WHATEVER REASON FACEBOOK OR
TWITTER DECIDED WEBELIEVE THAT
THAT.
YOU KNOW IT DOESN'T
MEET OUR STANDARDS OF CONDUCT.
AND YOU HAVE NO RECOURSE YOU
HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO RECOURSE NOW
TO GO -- AND SAY NO HATE EACH
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS IS NOT
PERMISSIBLE THIS IS YOU KNOW YOU
CAN'T MAKE WERE IF WE'RE GONNA
SAY NO HEY THEIR PRIVATE COMPANY
AND THERE'S NOTHING WE CAN DO
ABOUT THIS.
I THINK WE'VE GOT A REAL PROBLEM
ON OUR HANDS -- ESPECIALLY
CONSIDERING HOW INFLUENTIAL --
THESE PLATFORMS ARE AND AND AND
HOW MUCH THEY REALLY BECOME A
PART OF OUR CIVIL DISCOURSE --
IN RECENT YEARS.
SO I THOUGHT HEY WORK WITH ME
AND AND I'M NOT GONNA.
I'M NOT GONNA STEAM ALL THIS
THING THROUGH -- YOU KNOW THAT
I'M HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
SOME LANGUAGE HELPS MAKE PEOPLE
MORE ACCOUNTABLE MAKES IT MORE.
COMPREHENSIVE -- YOU KNOW BUT AS
I SAID I THINK I'M THE ONLY
VEHICLE TRYING TO DO SOME LET'S
TRY AND KEEP THIS MOVING FORWARD
SO WE CAN DO THAT. THREE AND ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENT.
SCENE -- YOU KNOW I JUST WANTED
TO SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
BRING IN THIS. FOR AND THANKS
FOR THE LIVELY DISCUSSION AND WE
ALL SEEMS LIKE WE ALL AGREED
THAT WE WOULD PROTECTIVE FREE
SPEECH AND WE ALL AGREED THAT
THERE ARE SOME PROBLEM.
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS AND GOV
I WOULD DEFINITELY BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOU AT AN AND ALL OF
YOU. TO BUDGET. TO TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE TO COME UP WITH A
MORE COMPREHENSIVE.
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION THIS BILL --
THE WAY I READ IT.
IS REALLY A NOTE.
YOU KNOW AS LONG AS THE THE
THIRD TO PROVIDER.
OF PUT ON THEIR THEIR TERROR
DETERRENCE ON CONDITIONS.
AND TO BE ABLE -- TO DO.
BILL COULD REMOVE YOU IN
REMOVING SOME OF THE POLITICAL.
QUOTE AND I BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
TO TO GETTING TO THE DEFINITION
OF WHAT TO POLITICAL CONTENT BUT
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO REMOVE
TOOLS CONTACT.
IS -- IF THEY PROVIDED AND THEIR
TERMS AND CONDITIONS SO IS
REALLY -- A NOTICE BILL BUT YOU
YOU HE GENERATES A VERY GOOD
CONVERSATION.
AND I'M HOPING THAT WILL
CONTINUE -- WORKING TO COME UP
WITH A COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION
THE LATER SO -- WORST DROUGHT
OUR SUPPORT OF REAL.
YOU ALL TO CLOSE HE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
RIGHT THANK YOU.
THERE'S NO MOTION YOU'RE RIGHT
[inaudible] SEVEN WHO WOULD
HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND MILLION
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN GALLAGHER TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
KANSEN CHU.
KANSEN CHU EYEING THE I DAVID
CHIU [inaudible]
READING.
NOT DAVID CHIU NOT VOTING CHOI.
CHOI I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NOT VOTING [inaudible]
THIS AREA.
HI.
NAZARIAN HI.
YOUR RECORD OF BILLS NOW THANK
YOU -- LEAVE THE ROOM THE ROLE
OPEN FOR IN THE APPS AND OKAY
WELL DONE.
ALL RIGHT HERE JONES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH